today I'm finally going to play the most
requested game of all time
one of my personal favorite video game
titles that did not just shape Who I am
but what I believe in I'm talking of
course about Club Penguin
No No
Oh
my favorite game on Club Penguin game on
desktop mobile devices will shut down
March 29 this can't be happening
I refuse to accept this Trump is
president fine Club Penguin shutting
down I say I say no it's time to stop
Hillary Clinton garbage okay I get it
pump one Hillary with [ __ ] but sir tell
me one good reason for this to happen
there's nothing you got nothing there
must be something that can be done there
must be one thing that I can do to use
my influence to Stockton as some of you
know I am right now at Club Penguin's
old office the server room out there
which is locked by the way I can't enter
it that server room I'm not joking right
I know it seems like I'm joking that
server room is running the club penguin
servers I got amazing [ __ ] internet
here's the [ __ ] best
I basically have the last lifeline of
club penguin in my hands and I'm not
gonna let some stupid idea stop my
favorite game of all time Club Penguin
will live let's look at the stats Club
Penguin got plenty of page with it but
we need more I want all of y'all to play
club things show them the power of the
rows show them what we can do we need to
protest against this he will not divide
us well penguin will not divide us he
will not divide us
poor penguin will not divide us say it
with me Club Penguin will not divide us
while penguin will not divide now my
friends in it and we haven't we suffered
enough
haven't we suffered enough
Bob penguin it's the number one works
you in world for Kim how can you take
that away from me
how can you just chew it up yeah my last
character got blown up Club Penguin's
virtual world will be closing March and
winning spent 20 minutes then why are
still you just you suffer every night I
can feel my claw pain in my arm
laughing
listen I know that
[Music]
we blend this
okay penguin
[Music]
I need to get in the server room this is
the server room it's locked but I have
the key card it works
it's the only room they line
come on Club Penguin come on
if I could get in here
I can stop it I can stop this horrible
thing and then we'll all just be a dream
you gotta like break in they always use
a card in movies it's literally just
that one thing oh so it's just that one
look that you can make it in here well I
think if you had a little flathead
screwdriver
yeah give me in and push this thing open
where did he go
this is legal
almost should we not be filming this
what the greatest good oh you thought it
was so anything oh my god what's inside
you do it it's gonna change the world
actually open yeah oh my god more
beautiful than I ever imagined
thank you this is Club Penguin's heart
and it's bleeding think there's a reason
they can oh [ __ ] sorry ashes to just an
act
could be worthless notice facial
recognition got a hit
Jesus Christ that's Jason Bourne
what are we doing I think sorry
we're gonna go Nikki [ __ ] I don't want
to get evicted I really don't want to
get it how are you going to play
something right now how are you going to
say Club Penguin from jail there must be
another way red you know when things get
harder there's no other way there seems
like there's no way out and you lose
hope you pray let's pray to the
protector of penguin the ones that speak
and protect they are what's the biggest
threat to penguin oh that's right
climate change I must pray to Al Gore we
need you
once again showing that Al Gore made the
Penguins save Club Penguin protect this
service when I go to jail so say we in
Al Gore's name Amen
[Music]
are you the reason Club Penguin is dying
yes it is me
I have inspected the Club Penguin
service long article waited for this day
and you know finally my dreams has been
realized
Club Penguin shall fall how did you did
it ahahahahahahaha I use your you die be
you Swedish gentle a healthy and I love
me how could I love that which is
unlovable
you were my puppet you stupid boy you
were my brother Ainsley you were
supposed to bring balance to the corpus
I'm the mrs. talent
ah
[Music]
you have guilty Kingsley but you will
not get math how do I you've met me
[Music]
you